The Joe Rogan experience,
either way,
the,
the important thing is that like seeing
those,
those images on those shows where
they're repeating over and over and over
again.
They have all these graphic images of
bodies and pulling things out of bodies
and it's like,
it's pretty intense that you're,
you're taking that stuff into your
psyche.
You're taking that stuff into your,
your bank of experiences.
I don't like sexual stuff on television
early.
He believed that.
You mean like girls making out or like
let's say I'm watching Diane Sawyer and
have like a condom commercial.
I'll lose my mind.
A condom commercial will bother you.
Oh,
because little kids really destroyed
tampon.
Commercial.
I want to choke myself and my wife was
in the room.
Are like your rants in the room with
some older woman since I was a kid.
KOTEX commercial.
I would sit down and look straight
ahead.
I never get so embarrassed in my life.
I don't want them to ask me if I know
and I don't want to fucking know the
blood comes out of this match
what you put up there.
That's got to do it.
But I'm just that don't even bring it
up.
You know,
there's some women that cute.
They think it's cute.
Like,
hold on,
I gotta go.
We gotta Tampon.
Listen,
I don't want to know.
I want to love you.
Bleed.
You just ruined everything for me.
I guess.
I don't want to know.
That's not really bothers me.
That bothers me.
The sight of blood.
No,
no,
no.
Decided talking about that.
You fucking pussies bleeding around me.
That's what I fucking hate when even
when they haven't been purse.
I get sick to my stomach.
I want to see a fucking tampon.
I don't want to fucking see a Tampon at
all.
Alright.
Right.
When I'm watching TV and a tampon
commercial comes up.
Even when I'm by myself.
I feel creepy.
That's so weird.
Condom commercials.
That new commercial with a chicken head
popping out on the fucking thing with
you.
Put on your finger.
Have you seen that fucking commercial
chick with the creepy finger?
You to relieve stress.
You know what meant?
I don't want to know about that shit.
Play to walk the fuck is that
Zombie?
Oh my God.
That is to put that away.
That's broken.
That one's broken.
That is just.
That means I didn't get that one fixed.
So this day,
anything back,
a little sprays,
anything bad and television.
10 o'clock drives me up the fucking
wall.
The reason I know this and I want to do
a shameless plug.
My Buddy Ben Wallace has this great
book,
the billionaire's vinegar,
and it's about the most expensive bottle
of wine ever sold,
but like what is good wine?
Do we know good wine when we taste?
It's fascinating.
Well,
if you get really old shit,
most likely it's not good anymore.
Well the problem is,
as his book explains is the problem is
no one.
This is a bottle.
The most expensive bottle of wine.
Every soul wound up being fraudulent,
but it was purported to be owned by
Thomas Jefferson.
Okay.
So for like Steve Forbes zoned for
awhile and all these different guys on
this bottle line,
one of the Koch brothers don't want it
for a while and in the end there's no
one around who can go.
I've had a lot of wine from that year.
Spray down the money.
Isn't crazy though that
these different rich guys had the wine
and sold it to each other,
like they passed it on Forbes,
stored in a,
put it in a in their corporate
headquarters and they had an a box,
like a glass lift boxes of decoration,
but they hadn't standing upright with a
heat lamp in there or dried that cork
out and the felt in the bottle.
So later when people were trying to
analyze what was in it,
there can never rule out the intrusion
of foreign substances which will not
allow them to find out what it was.
The guy they eventually like is why the
guy who created the hoax would take
really good wine and do weird stuff to
it.
Like you'd put a little bit of vanilla
extract in here or he'd put some dirt
from his gutter in.
They're just weird things he could do to
kind of throw people and then guys that
are like big swinging dicks about wine,
we're tasting.
They'd be like,
Oh yeah,
I got it.
It's a brilliant book,
man.
Okay.
Here's a serious question.
Is there a guy that has ever existed
that has a full suit of armor in his
house that isn't a douchebag?
Nope.
Well,
I mean,
comic book collector guys aren't really
Douche bags,
you know,
they like that shit.
You know,
like they have like a real suit of armor
in their house.
I've almost bought at an armored helmet
the other day.
I saw helmets.
Helmets are Kinda dope.
Yeah.
I almost bought one of those so I could
see it.
I would say last case I would say,
uh,
the same can be said about those dime
store Indians.
The cigar store Indian
or the black jockeys that you put on
your lawn.
Oh,
that's rude.
How about people who have like little
gremlins and shit on there?
The elves are those,
what are they?
Yeah,
my step Mama House east on her front
porch today.
If it starts to rain,
she puts her raincoat on it and then if
it's like halloween she dresses up in a
little costume.
Was like this big ceramic geese.
And then I,
I was,
I always make fun of it.
And then somebody came,
broke it recently and she was so sad
about it.
So now she has all these stupid geese
outfits and she can't find another one
of them.
So are you kidding me?
Ceramic.
Geez.
What happened today?
It was the worst day of my life.
Someone cracked my ceramic birds.
I had that one that I leave.
It makes me so happy.
I come home,
I see my ceramic duck.
I got him into Toronto World Fairy Sixty
two.
It's x and they don't make them that
much anymore.
He's beauty.
He defined my yard.
I swear you to look at me.
He was my friend.
I know that sounds retarded.
I don't care.
He was my friend.
Ever since he left.
Ever since Jimmy left,
he's gone.
Ever since gone.
A
house is haunted.
Gone.
I feel a little crazy.
I can't sleep at night because I feel
like I failed him and he's going to kill
me in my sleep.
I should've.
I should've gotten them a coat of armor.
It was my little chally.
I had a name for room charlie the duck
and now he's dead.
I had illustrated books I made about him
over the years.
He's gonna come back and kill those
punks that broke them.
That's fucking Rad.
Isn't a Stephen King movie about a
fucking evil ceramic duck.
Some kids break.
It goes out and cuts their throat and
their sleep.
Just imagine that you're waking up in a
giant ceramic Daca just trying to throw
it out.
Oh,
I can.
I'm never going to get tired of seeing
the neighborhood punks get beat up for
doing something wrong somehow.
You love that story
recording.
Oh,
it is already.
What the fuck son?